The year is 1863. It's June 2nd and it's 4 o'clock in the morning. Light is beginning to creep into the sky, but the full moon still hangs heavy, its reflection bright in the winding Combehi River. And it's by this light that an old man, rail thin, leaves his cabin, joining his wife and the other enslaved men and women heading out to work the South Carolina rice fields. The slave cabins are about a mile from the rice fields. That's Pulitzer Prize-winning historian, Dr. Edda Fields Black. They would have walked a mile through grass and moss, infested with snakes in the dark. And then they would be standing in the rice fields, which were infested with alligators. The old man, named Minus Hamilton, ignores the snakes and the alligators and begins to hoe. This morning is like any other. Birds call from reeds, mosquitoes, buzz.
时间是1863年。那是6月2日的凌晨4点。天刚蒙蒙亮，但一轮满月仍然高悬，它明亮的倒影在蜿蜒的孔巴希河上闪烁。借着这月光，一个骨瘦如柴的老人离开了他的简陋小屋，与他的妻子以及其他正前往南卡罗来纳州稻田劳作的奴役男女汇合。奴隶木屋距离稻田大约有一英里。那是普利策奖得主、历史学家埃达·菲尔兹-布莱克博士。在黑暗中，他们要走上一英里穿过长满青草和苔藓、毒蛇横行的地面。然后他们会站在鳄鱼出没的稻田里。这个名叫迈纳斯·汉密尔顿的老人无视蛇和鳄鱼，开始挥锄劳作。这个清晨和往常一样。芦苇丛中传来鸟鸣，蚊虫嗡嗡作响。
The horse carrying the overseer flicks its tail. But then everything changes. Minus Hamilton sees the U.S. Army gunboats coming up the river. U.S. Army gunboats coming up his river and docking at the edge of the plantation. And Minus cannot believe who he sees coming out of the vessel. Minus Hamilton sees young black men in uniform for the first time, and he's completely awestruck by this to see these armed black men who have come to liberate him,
监工骑着的马甩了甩尾巴。但随后一切都变了。迈纳斯·汉密尔顿看到美国陆军炮艇正顺河而上。美国陆军炮艇正顺着他的河而上，并在种植园边缘停靠。迈纳斯简直不敢相信他从船上看到的人。迈纳斯·汉密尔顿第一次看到身穿制服的年轻黑人男性，他被这些前来解放他的武装黑人深深地震撼了，
and he identifies them as the Brack soldiers so presumptuous. Presumptuous. Minus repeats this word to himself, shaking his head. He talks about their stature, how they hold their heads up. This is an 88-year-old man born in bondage who likely thought he would die in bondage and someone who has spent his life in a subservient position. And now he sees these young, armed black men who hold their heads up and they march onto the plantation and begin to burn down everything that the man who held him in bondage.
他认出他们是黑人士兵，太傲慢了。傲慢。迈纳斯摇着头，对自己重复着这个词。他谈到他们的身材，他们是如何昂首挺胸的。这是一个生于奴役之中的88岁老人，他原本以为自己会在奴役中死去，他的一生都在卑微的地位中度过。而现在，他看到了这些年轻、武装的黑人，他们昂首挺胸，踏上种植园，开始烧毁那个曾将他奴役的人留下的一切。
His old life is going up in flames, and a new one awaits him. So when the overseer yells at Minus to follow him into the woods away from the soldiers, for the old man, there is no choice. Minus Hamilton basically says, Lord, I didn't care nothing at all, I was going to the boat. When Edda Fields Black came upon Minus' story, she wasn't looking for it. She was researching an entirely different project, but it suddenly came to her what he was describing. I realized that he's actually talking about the Cumbie raid, the largest and most successful slave rebellion in U.S. history. The Combe River Raid was a Union military operation during the Civil War, where three boats, guided by none other than Harriet Tubman, liberated more than 700 enslaved people in a single night, including minus Hamilton.
他旧的生活付之一炬，一个新的生活在等待着他。因此，当监工大喊让迈纳斯跟他一起逃进树林、远离士兵时，对这位老人来说，已经别无选择。迈纳斯·汉密尔顿基本上是说，天哪，我一点不在乎，我要上船去。当埃达·菲尔兹-布莱克偶然发现迈纳斯的历史时，她并不是在寻找它。她当时正在研究一个完全不同的项目，但突然间，她明白了他在描述什么。我意识到他其实是在谈论孔巴希突袭，这是美国历史上规模最大、最成功的奴隶起义。孔巴希河突袭是内战期间联邦军队的一次军事行动，在哈莉特·塔布曼的亲自带领下，三艘船在短短一个夜晚解放了700多名被奴役的人，其中包括迈纳斯·汉密尔顿。
The story of the Combe raid is not new, but Eda had never read anything from the perspective of someone who had been freed in it. And I found the voice of Minus Hamilton. It was so striking and it wasn't the complete account, but it was enough to really tantalize me. This was a formerly enslaved man who was telling the story of his own liberation. So that was enough. I was hooked. I wanted to know more, and I dug. She dug around for more accounts like this, but minus the story was kind of a one-off. After the raid, a writer took a liking to him and wrote down his story. That was it, so she was kind of stuck.
孔巴希突袭的故事并不新鲜，但埃达从未读过任何来自其中被解放者视角的内容。我找到了迈纳斯·汉密尔顿的声音。它是如此引人注目，虽然不是完整的记录，但足以真正吸引我。这是一个曾经被奴役的人在讲述他自己获得解放的故事。这就足够了。我被迷住了。我想知道更多，于是我进行了挖掘。她四处挖掘更多这样的记录，但迈纳斯的故事算是一个孤例。突袭结束后，一位作家很喜欢他，便记下了他的故事。仅此而已，所以她一度陷入了困境。
But through her digging, Eda came across a unique set of documents, mostly untapped by historians that would unlock a whole world she didn't know was possible. You could say it was an accident. You could say it was serendipity. It was probably all of the above. But I stumbled upon the pension files. The pension files, meaning the records the government kept when people applied to receive a pension after serving in the Civil War. Dry, bureaucratic documents, not exactly riveting material.
但通过她的挖掘，埃达偶然发现了一套独特的文献，这些文献大部分未被历史学家开发，它们将打开一个她以前不知道的世界。你可以说这是一场意外。你可以说这是机缘巧合。可能上述因素都有。但我偶然发现了抚恤金档案。抚恤金档案，也就是政府在人们参加内战后申请领取抚恤金时保存的记录。枯燥的官僚文件，算不上什么引人入胜的材料。
But the ones Edda found contained something she wasn't expecting. Many of the men liberated in the Colmbee raid would go on to serve in the Union Army, like their presumptuous liberators. And in their pension applications, their names, histories, and stories are recorded for the first time. From 99% Invisible in BBC Studios, this is the history of the United States and 100 Objects. I'm Roman Mars. Today, the U.S. Army pension files and how they unlocked a whole new story of the largest and most successful slave rebellion in U.S. history. So let's get to Harriet Tubman. She's a key player in this story, whether or not people know of the raid.
但埃达找到的那些文件中包含了一些她意料之外的东西。在孔巴希突袭中被解放的许多人后来都加入了联邦军队，就像他们那些傲慢的解放者一样。在他们的抚恤金申请中，他们的名字、历史和故事第一次被记录了下来。这里是由BBC录音室制作的《99%隐形》，讲述的是美国历史与100件物品的故事。我是罗曼·马尔斯。今天，我们将探讨美国陆军抚恤金档案，以及它们如何开启美国历史上最大、最成功奴隶起义的全新故事。那么，让我们来谈谈哈莉特·塔布曼。她是这个故事中的关键人物，不管人们是否知道这次突袭。
They know about Harriet Tubman. But I think it's worth pausing here to take a moment to talk about just the incredible thing she did as a young woman. Could you just tell us a little bit about her? Yeah. So Tubman is such an extraordinary, extraordinary figure. She liberated herself from bondage on the Maryland Eastern Shore in 1849. And from that point on, she made 13 trips back into the land of bondage, back to the same county and occasionally the same plantation where she had been held in bondage. These are enormous acts of selflessness.
他们都知道哈莉特·塔布曼。但我认为在这里停顿一下，花点时间谈谈她作为一个年轻女性所做的那件不可思议的事情是很有价值的。你能给我们简单介绍一下她吗？可以。所以塔布曼是一个非常、非常非凡的人物。她在1849年从马里兰州东海岸的奴役中解放了自己。从那时起，她13次返回奴役之地，回到她曾经被奴役的同一个县，有时甚至是同一个种植园。这些都是极其无私的壮举。
I liken it to putting one's hand in the mouth of an alligator. When she liberated herself, she had been able to take her. her hand out from the alligator's mouth. Most of us would just go in the opposite direction and leave the alligator alone. It's fair to say. But Tubman, 13 more times, she puts it in, she takes it out. She puts it in, she takes it out. 13 more times.
我把它比作把手伸进鳄鱼的嘴里。当她解放自己时，她已经能够把手从鳄鱼嘴里抽出来了。我们大多数人只会朝相反的方向走，离鳄鱼远远的。这样说很公平。但塔布曼，又去了13次，她把手伸进去，又抽出来。她把手伸进去，又抽出来。又去了13次。
I mean, who does that? She rescues about 70 people personally, rescue. brings out of slavery 70 people. This is the Harriet Tubman that most of us know about. But our story begins where a lot of that history ends. So as the Civil War is nearing and after she makes her last rescue mission and is not able to rescue her sister and her sister's children, Tubman is being advised really to kind of cool it, right?
我的意思是，谁会这么做？她亲手拯救了大约70人，救援。把70人带出了奴隶制。这就是我们大多数人所知道的哈莉特·塔布曼。但我们的故事始于许多历史结束的地方。因此，随着内战临近，在她完成最后一次救援任务却未能救出她的姐姐和姐姐的孩子后，塔布曼被建议冷静下来，对吧？
This war is getting ready to happen. and we don't know what's going to go on. At this point, Tubman is living in New York and is a well-known part of abolitionist networks. And it is through these networks that she gets a new opportunity to help. And once the war gets started, the governor of Massachusetts
这场战争就要爆发了，我们不知道会发生什么。此时，塔布曼住在纽约，是废奴主义网络中知名的一员。正是通过这些网络，她得到了一个新的帮助机会。一旦战争爆发，马萨诸塞州长
makes the arrangements for her to serve as a spy for the U.S. Army. A spy recruited by the army. So in May 1862, Harriet Tubman heads down to her first. posting, a place called Beaufort, South Carolina, a town of old plantation houses, live oaks, and eerie hanging moss. It sits on Port Royal Island, one of a chain of so-called sea islands along the coast, and it has just been captured by the Union. In November 1861, the U.S. Navy captured Beaufort, Port Royal, and the sea islands from the Confederacy.
为她做出安排，让她担任美军间谍。一个被军队招募的间谍。因此，在1862年5月，哈莉特·塔布曼前往她的第一个岗位，一个名为南卡罗来纳州博福特的地方，那是一个拥有古老种植园房屋、活栎树和诡异垂挂苔藓的小镇。它坐落在皇家港岛上，这是一连串沿海所谓的海洋岛屿之一，刚刚被联邦占领。1861年11月，美国海军从邦联手中夺取了博福特、皇家港和这些海洋岛屿。
And the next day the U.S. Army occupied these territories. But before the U.S. Navy's ships arrived, the plantation owners, slave owners, fled. And they left behind about 8,000 enslaved people. And the U.S. Army decrees that it's not going to return the property, in quotes, of the Confederates. we're not enforcing the Fugitive Slave Act anymore. You have forfeited your property and we're going to keep them, right? They become contrabands of war. And eventually the U.S. Army frees all the people who were enslaved on Port Royal and the Sea Islands, creating a kind of free city.
第二天，美国陆军占领了这些领土。但在美国海军的船只到达之前，种植园主、奴隶主们逃跑了。他们留下了大约8000名被奴役的人。美国陆军下令，它不会将邦联成员的所谓“财产”归还。我们不再执行《逃亡奴隶法》。你们已经失去了财产，我们要把他们留下，对吧？他们成为了战争的禁忌品。最终，美国陆军解放了所有在皇家港和海洋岛屿上被奴役的人，建立了一种自由城市。
So the U.S. Army begins to employ people who were able to work and house and feed. and take care of people who couldn't. So it's in this context that hundreds of northern abolitionists come down, opening schools, clinics, shops, churches. And this is what's stunning to me is this is South Carolina. Like this is a free community deep in Confederate territory. Like the fact that this is happening in South Carolina is really stunning. Yeah. Well, I like.
于是，美国陆军开始雇用那些有工作能力的人，为他们提供住房和食物，并照顾那些不能工作的人。正是在这种背景下，数百名北方废奴主义者南下，开办学校、诊所、商店、教堂。最让我震惊的是，这里是南卡罗来纳州。就像这是深入邦联领土深处的一个自由社区。这竟然发生在南卡罗来纳州，这真的太令人震惊了。是的。嗯，我喜欢
to say it's the belly of the beast. It's sort of an oasis, but I'm sure it felt very tenuous, just because the proximity of the Confederacy. There's no buffer. There's no border. There's no barrier. It's right there. So Beaufort and the wider Port Royal Island is becoming this experiment in what a post-slavery society might look like. But that's not the only radical experiment going on in the quintessentially southern town. Colonel Thomas Wentworth Higginson, a famous writer and abolitionist, the one who later interviewed, minus Hamilton,
说这是野兽的腹地。这有点像一个绿洲，但我确信由于靠近邦联，它感觉非常脆弱。没有缓冲区。没有边界。没有屏障。它就在那里。因此，博福特和更广泛的皇家港岛正在成为后奴隶制社会可能是什么样的一种社会实验。但这并不是这个典型的南方小镇上进行的唯一的激进实验。托马斯·韦特沃思·希金森上校，一位著名的作家和废奴主义者，就是后来采访迈纳斯·汉密尔顿的那个人，
described it like this. Five minutes walk beyond the live oaks will bring you to something so unsouthern that the whole southern coast at this moment trembles at the suggestion of such a thing, the camp of a regiment of freed slaves. For the first time in U.S. history, the Union Army is also building a company
他是这样描述的：从活栎树再往前走五分钟，就会带你来到一个如此不南方的场所，以至于此时整个南方海岸都为这种暗示而颤抖，那是一个由被解放奴隶组成的团的营地。美国历史上第一次，联邦军队也在皇家港建立了一支
of Black soldiers in Port Royal, arming and training the formerly enslaved. It's a radical idea. Higginson, who actually led the first Black company, wrote, they had home and household and freedom to fight for, not just the abstraction of the union. And Harriet Tubman comes down in this context. Technically, she's a northern volunteer,
黑人士兵连队，武装和培训曾经被奴役的人。这是一个激进的想法。亲自领导第一支黑人连队的希金森写道：他们有家、有家庭和需要为之奋斗的自由，而不仅仅是联邦的抽象概念。哈莉特·塔布曼就是在这种背景下来到这里的。从技术上讲，她是一名北方志愿者，
but she comes down to serve as a spy. Harriet Tubman's job would be to gather intelligence for the Army from the Beaufort's growing population of people who had escaped slavery and made their way to the free oasis. This is what Harriet Tubman did. So we know that she was in downtown Beaufort working in the refugee camps. So as the freedom seekers came from the Confederate plantation, she was there to talk to them and find out what they knew. And they had a lot of information that the union wanted and that could be beneficial. to the union. Before arriving
但她南下来担任间谍。哈莉特·塔布曼的工作是为军队从博福特不断增加的逃离奴隶制并来到自由绿洲的人口中收集情报。这就是哈莉特·塔布曼所做的。所以我们知道她当时在博福特市中心在难民营里工作。因此，当追求自由的人从邦联种植园来到这里时，她在那里与他们交谈并了解他们所知道的信息。他们掌握了许多联邦想要并且对联邦有利的大量信息。在到达
in the refugee camps of Beaufort, many of the formerly enslaved had been made to work for the Confederate cause. Whether it was building fortifications, moving and hauling, armaments, serving Confederate troops, and individuals, especially officers, brought their slaves with them to camp.
博福特的难民营之前，许多曾经被奴役的人曾被迫为邦联事业劳作。无论是建造防御工事、搬运和拖运军械，还是为邦联军队服务，个人，尤其是军官，都把他们的奴隶带到了军营。
So they were in the camp, cooking everything, washing everything, fixing everything, building everything. And Tubman was there to debrief them, as one of the CIA commanders says. And then she passed this intelligence back to the U.S. Army commanders. Also, the Confederate Army had planted explosives along the river in case of a union attack. Except they didn't actually do the labor. They had the people held in bondage do that.
所以他们在营地里做饭、洗衣服、修理一切、建造一切。正如一位中情局指挥官所说，塔布曼当时就在那里向他们了解情况。然后她把这些情报传递给美国陆军指挥官。此外，邦联军队还在河边埋设了炸药，以防联邦袭击。不过他们实际上并没有自己动手。他们让被奴役的人来做这件事。
People who are now flooding into Beaufort and could tell Tubman exactly where the mines were planted. And these freedom seekers also taught Tubman about the third. terrain, where the river bends, where the sandbars are, because these plantations sit on a very different landscape than the one she grew up in. When Americans, if Americans think about slavery, we think about cotton. So the rice plantations are, and I should say the tidal rice plantations, they are located in the coastal wetlands. The marshland where the rice grows is home to deadly cotton-mouth snakes and silent slithering
现在正涌入博福特的人们可以准确地告诉塔布曼地雷埋在哪里。这些追求自由的人还向塔布曼介绍了第三种地形，河湾在哪里，沙洲在哪里，因为这些种植园的地貌与她长大的地方截然不同。当美国人，如果美国人想到奴隶制，我们就会想到棉花。所以水稻种植园位于，我应该说潮汐水稻种植园，它们位于沿海湿地。水稻生长的沼泽地里栖息着致命的棉口蛇和静静滑行的
alligators, but it's also home to a much smaller but even more deadly animal. Mosquitoes breed in water, right? And so it creates this awful, deadly disease environment. The people working these plantations often lived with chronic malaria. What happens is that malaria shatters the immune system. And so having chronic malaria means that the immune system is then not able to fight off other things, right? Something as simple as upper respiratory ailments killed otherwise healthy people. It means that women gave birth to babies who did not thrive. So children, infants are very vulnerable. Elderly people and people with compromised immune system is very vulnerable. And so the death rates on these rice plantations are second only to sugar
短吻鳄，但这里也栖息着一种体型小得多却更致命的动物。蚊子在水中繁殖，对吧？因此，这就造成了一种可怕、致命的疾病环境。在这些种植园劳作的人经常带着慢性疟疾生活。发生的情况是，疟疾会摧毁免疫系统。因此，患有慢性疟疾意味着免疫系统无法抵御其他疾病，对吧？诸如上呼吸道疾病这样简单的事情就会杀死原本健康的人。这意味着女性生下的婴儿无法茁壮成长。因此，儿童、婴儿非常脆弱。老年人和免疫系统受损的人非常脆弱。因此，这些水稻种植园的死亡率仅次于加勒比地区的糖
plantations in the Caribbean, right, where the life expectancy was seven years. Rice plantations are second to that. There's one time of year when the mosquitoes are particularly bad, so bad that the plantation calendar is organized around it. June is the sickly season. So this is when rice is growing. in the rice fields in standing water, and that stagnant waters breeding malaria, is breeding mosquitoes, and the mosquitoes carry malaria. And so white plantation owners, slave owners, and overseers
种植园，在那里的平均预期寿命只有七年。水稻种植园仅次于它们。一年中有一个时期蚊子特别猖獗，以至于种植园的历法都是围绕它安排的。6月是多病季节。所以这时水稻正在水田中生长，积水滋生了疟疾，滋生了蚊子，而蚊子传播疟疾。因此，白人种植园主、奴隶主和监工
would leave the area by the middle of May. Almost all the white people in the area would leave the plantations and the deadly disease environment, retreating to summer homes in Charleston, leaving just a few overseers. and the enslaved to keep working the fields. Even the Confederate Army had reassigned its troops. There were no troops stationed on the Cumbie River.
会在5月中旬左右离开该地区。几乎该地区的所有白人都将离开种植园和致命的疾病环境，撤退到查尔斯顿的避暑别墅，只留下少数监工和被奴役的人继续在田里劳作。甚至邦联军队也重新调动了军队。孔巴希河上没有驻军。
No army except two lonely soldiers monitoring the river. No plantation owners. No troops. It's a pretty dang perfect time to carry out a daring raid. Can you give me a sense of what is happening in the war this time? Like how is it going for the Union Army? What is the vibe like? Yeah.
除了两名孤零零监视这条河的士兵外，没有军队。没有种植园主。没有军队。这是执行一次大胆突袭的绝佳时机。你能跟我讲讲当时战争正在发生什么吗？比如联邦军队进展如何？氛围是怎样的？是的。
It's not going so well. They hadn't had a win, like a real win in a while. And people were not happy. Morale was low because the union was on the defense and couldn't seem to get back on the offense. And I think South Carolina, in a lot of ways, was a sore spot for the union. This is where the first shots of the Civil War were fired.
进展得不太顺利。他们已经有一段时间没有赢过仗了，没有真正赢过了。人们很不高兴。士气低落，因为联邦处于守势，似乎无法恢复攻势。我认为南卡罗来纳州在许多方面是联邦的痛处。内战的第一枪就是在这里打响的。
But a raid. Now, a raid might boost morale. It would be carried out by some of the new black troops that had been training in Beaufort. Their aim would be to liberate more enslaved people, some of whom would join them in the army, swell the union ranks. Their other goal was simple, to burn everything in sight. So let's talk about the raid. Everyone at Beaufort has been working towards this raid for me. months, gathering information, they finally arrived to the night in question. Bring me to that night. So on June 1st, at about 9 p.m., so this is in the summertime, it's just getting pitch black dark. This is the time when the boats leave the docks in downtown Beaufort. And they are sailing under the light of the full moon. There are three boats, one gunboat, and two transport steamers. And the transport steamers were brought along to bring the freedom seekers back in the raid. Harriet Tubman told the Union Army that she'd come on the raid if it was led by a man named Colonel James Montgomery.
但一次突袭。现在，一次突袭可能会提振士气。它将由一些在博福特受训的新黑人部队执行。他们的目标是解放更多被奴役的人，其中一些人将加入军队，壮大联邦队伍。他们的另一个目标很简单，烧毁视线内的一切。让我们来谈谈突袭。博福特的每个人为了这次突袭已经忙碌了几个月，收集信息，他们终于迎来了那个夜晚。把我带到那个夜晚。所以6月1日晚上9点左右，这是夏天，天刚刚黑透。这是船只离开博福特市中心码头的时间。它们在满月的月光下航行。有三艘船，一艘炮艇和两艘运输轮船。带上运输轮船是为了在突袭中把追求自由的人接回来。哈莉特·塔布曼告诉美国陆军，如果由一个叫詹姆斯·蒙哥马利上校的人领导，她就会参加突袭。
Montgomery is a well-known white abolitionist, a man with a history of freeing slaves during his raids. He is a man Harriet Tubman trusts. So that night, Tubman is up on the front boat with Montgomery. With her are eight or nine men under her command. These are her very best informants, a group of black men who would act as spies, scouts, and pilots during the raid. Then there are the soldiers, one battery of white soldiers, and then 300 black soldiers from the second South Carolina volunteers. It's hard to imagine what these black soldiers were feeling as the gunboats pulled out from the harbor. Many of them had been enslaved on the very plantations they were returning to,
蒙哥马利是一位著名的白人废奴主义者，在突袭中解放奴隶有着悠久的历史。他是哈莉特·塔布曼信任的人。所以在那个夜晚，塔布曼和蒙哥马利一起在前船上。和她在一起的还有她指挥下的八九个人。这些人是她最好的情报人员，是一群在突袭中担任间谍、侦察员和领航员的黑人。然后是士兵，一个连的白人士兵，然后是来自第二南卡罗来纳志愿军的300名黑人士兵。很难想象当炮艇从港口驶出时，这些黑人士兵内心作何感想。他们许多人曾在他们现在正要返回的种植园里被奴役，
plantations where they still had family members held in bondage. They were going to war against slavery, right? They were going to war to free other people who were still enslaved. Together, under the light of the full moon, they begin to make their stealthy way up the tidal waters of the Kalmahuey River. But very quickly, something goes wrong. One of the transport steamers ran aground, and it was about three hours until the next high tide, which could potentially have dislodged it. They couldn't sit there for three hours and be sitting ducks for, you know, whatever the Confederacy might have for them.
在那些种植园里，他们仍然有亲人在受奴役。他们要去为反对奴隶制而战，对吧？他们要为解放其他仍在受奴役的人而战。在满月的月光下，他们一起悄悄地顺着卡尔马休伊河的潮水向上游驶去。但很快，出了问题。其中一艘运输轮船搁浅了，距离下一次可能使其脱浅的高潮还有大约三个小时。他们不能在那里坐三个小时，成为任由邦联摆布的活靶子。
So they had to abandon it and continue with two boats. And I suspect that that was really heartbreaking for, Tubman, the second South Carolina volunteers, her scouts and pilots, all of these folks who are formerly enslaved. It must have really been heartbreaking for them to think that now they're only going to be able to bring half as many people down from the Cumbie. The gunships are able to move up the river unseen until about 3 a.m. That's when the boat encounters the only two Confederate soldiers the army left behind in a lonely outpost on the river. The Confederates quickly realize that They are vastly outnumbered.
所以他们不得不放弃它，用两艘船继续前进。我猜这一定让塔布曼、第二南卡罗来纳志愿军、她的侦察兵和领航员，所有这些曾经被奴役的人感到心碎。他们想到现在只能从孔巴希河带走一半的人，这一定让他们非常心碎。炮艇能够在河上无声无息地前进，直到凌晨3点左右。就在那时，船遇到了军队留在河边一个孤立前哨站里的仅有的两名邦联士兵。邦联士兵很快意识到他们寡不敌众。
They fled. They fled. And there are some wonderful newspaper accounts that talk about them fleeing so quickly that they left their blankets warm. The Union soldiers on the raid knew that Confederate reinforcements would eventually arrive. So the clock was now ticking. And in the meantime, the two Union boats are right where they wanted to be. They've reached the rice plantations. They make a furtive stop at a first plantation and let some soldiers.
他们逃跑了。他们逃跑了。有一些精彩的报纸报道说，他们逃跑得如此之快，以至于他们的毛毯还是温的。参加突袭的联邦士兵知道邦联的增援部队迟早会赶到。所以时间在流逝。与此同时，两艘联邦船只正处于它们想要的位置。它们到达了水稻种植园。它们在一个种植园秘密停下，放下一部分士兵，然后继续逆流而上，再次停下，放下更多士兵。士兵们上岸了。他们前往种植园并开始纵火。你知道的，烧毁马厩、谷仓，谷仓里装着去年的水稻收成。
out and then continue up the river and make another stop, letting more soldiers out. The soldiers get on land. They went to the plantations and started burning things down. You know, burning down stables, barns, and the barns contained the previous year's rice harvest.
他们烧毁了大部分房屋，也就是种植园主及其家人居住的主宅。他们走到稻田里，打开水利灌溉系统的闸门，让海水涌入。他们杀死了田里正在生长的水稻。这些水稻种植园被认为是南方这一地区的粮仓。
They burned most of the houses, the manor houses where the plantation owner and his family lived. They go to the rice fields and they open the gates of the hydraulic irrigation system and let in all the salt water. And they kill the rice crop that's growing in the fields. These rice plantations are considered the breadbasket of this part of the South.
因此，当他们摧毁庄稼和烧毁食物储备时，他们对邦联造成了巨大的打击。但就在这一切发生的同时，行动的另一部分开始了。他们不仅让士兵上岸，还派出小船。这些小船把追求自由的人接回船上。刚刚摆脱奴隶身份的黑人士兵开始向在种植园劳工的被奴役者大声呼喊。他们一边走一边挥舞着旗帜，试图吸引追求自由的人的注意。眼前这一幕让80
So as they destroy crops and burn food stores, they are dealing a massive blow to the Confederacy. But as all of this is happening, the other part of the operation begins. Not only do they disembark soldiers, but they, They also send out rowboats. And those rowboats bring the freedom seekers back to the boat. The black soldiers, fresh out of slavery themselves, begin to call out to the enslaved people working on the plantations. They walked up and down waving flags, trying to attract the attention of the freedom seekers. And one of the people watching in utter amazement as this unfolds is 80.
岁、骨瘦如柴的迈纳斯·汉密尔顿惊呆了，他是目击者之一。他描述了被奴役的人们在稻田里锄草时，第一次看到联邦炮艇顺河而上。他谈到一个监工骑着马和他们一起在稻田里。所以监工把被奴役的人所看到的一切看在眼里，他向他们大喊北方佬来了，要把他们卖到古巴。他们应该跟着他进树林躲藏。迈纳斯·汉密尔顿基本上是说，
year old rail thin minus Hamilton. He describes the enslaved people being in the rice fields, hoeing rice, when they first saw the union gunboats coming up the river. And he talks about an overseer being in the rice fields with them on horseback. And so the overseer is seeing exactly what the enslaved people see. and he is shouting to them that the Yankees have come and are going to sell them to Cuba. And they should follow him to the woods and hide. And Minas Hamilton basically says,
大家都往另一个方向跑了。我要上船去。迈纳斯和他的妻子海加尔那天都在田里。他们一起朝炮艇走去，什么也没带。他们真的只有身上穿的衣服。他有一条裤子和一件衬衫，而她只有一件连衣裙和一个头巾。他感叹他的两条毯子，这是他唯一觉得可以称为属于自己的东西，
everybody went the other way. I was going to the boat. Minus and his wife Hagar are both in the fields that day. Together they make their way to the gunboat, carrying nothing with them. They really only had the clothing on their backs. He had a pair of pants and a shirt, and she only had just a single frock and a head tie. He laments that his two blankets, which are the only two things that he feels he can call his own,
他的两条毯子在奴隶小屋里，他不得不把它们留下。但时间紧迫，不容浪费。自由之船就在这里。你可以想象，迈纳斯·汉密尔顿和他的妻子都是老人。他很可能是这些孔巴希稻田里年纪最大的人之一。所以当他们向船移动时，人们从他们身后赶上来催促他们。人们告诉他们邦联的人要来了。对此，迈纳斯·汉密尔顿的妻子海加尔基本上说，我很想看看他们能不能阻止我们。
his two blankets are in the slave cabin and he has to leave them behind. But there is no time to waste. The freedom boat is here. So as you can imagine, Minus Hamilton and his wife are elderly. He was likely one of the oldest people on these Cumbi rice plantations. So as they're moving to the boat, people are coming up behind them and telling them to hurry. People are telling them that the Confederates are coming. To which Minus Hamilton's wife, Hagar, basically says, I like to see them try and stop us.
她告诉他们快点，对吧？来吧。来吧。我们要上船去。我们不担心这里的邦联人。这对老夫妇欣喜若狂。迈纳斯回头看到他被奴役的种植园在燃烧。后来采访迈纳斯的联邦希金森上校问他当时是什么感觉。
She tells them to come on, right? Come on. Come on. And we're going to the boat. We're not worried about the Confederates here. The elderly couple are giddy. Minus looks back and sees the plantation where he was held in bondage burn. Union Colonel Higginson, who later interviewed Minus, asked him how that moment felt.
迈纳斯·汉密尔顿笑着说：“上帝啊，主人，我一点都不在乎。我要上船去。”你知道，我——他就像是，我不会回头。我不在乎。我要把这一切都抛在脑后，我要去追求自由。但迈纳斯对那天真正记忆深刻的是那些身穿制服的黑人。这就是他用了那个非常特殊的词“傲慢”，并重复了三遍。黑人士兵是如此傲慢。你怎么看待“傲慢”这个词？
And Minus Hamilton laughs and says, Lord, Master, I didn't care nothing at all. I was going to the boat. You know, I – and he's like, I'm not looking back. I don't care. I'm leaving this all behind and I am going to freedom. But what mine is really remembered from that day were the black men in uniform. This is when he uses that very particular word, presumptuous, and repeats it three times. The Brack soldier is so presumptuous. What do you make of that word presumptuous?
在这一刻使用这样一个有趣而酷的词。它给你留下了什么印象？给我的印象是，看着他们，看着这些身穿制服的年轻武装人员不必垂下眼睛。他们不必低下头。他们没有向白人卑躬屈膝，对吧？相反，他们来到这里，就像是要把整个世界付之一炬，对吧？他很可能认为他们在摧毁奴隶制体制。他们正在把它烧成灰烬。
It's such an interesting and cool word to use in this moment. What does it strike you? It strikes me as he's looking at them and looking at the fact that these young armed men in uniform don't have to lower their eyes. They don't have to lower their heads. They're not cowing to white people, right? Instead, they're here and they're like turning this whole world on fire, right? He likely saw them as destroying the institution of slavery. They're burning it down.
而在大火中，他们正在解放我们。与此同时，哈莉特·塔布曼一如既往地身处前线。我们知道塔布曼坐小船去了一个种植园，她去了奴隶小屋。我说过，有被奴役的人在稻田里劳作，那些身强力壮的人，包括88岁的迈纳斯·汉密尔顿和他的妻子，一大清早就已经在田里劳作了。所以留在小屋里的人更加年迈，甚至体弱多病、残疾、年纪太小而无法工作的儿童，以及刚生完孩子或有很小哺乳婴儿的妇女。这些人
And in burning it down, they are setting us free. In the meantime, Harriet Tubman is, as ever, on the front lines. We know that Tubman got out on a rowboat and went. to a plantation and she went to the slave cabins. And I've said that there were enslaved people working in the rice fields, the able-bodied people, including 88-year-old Minus Hamilton and his wife, were working in the fields that early in the morning. So the people who were left in the cabins were extremely even more elderly, but in firm, disabled children who were too young to work, women who had recently given birth or had very young nursing infants. Those are the people
就是被留在奴隶小屋里的人。塔布曼去了小屋去接这些最脆弱的人。她还记得那个美妙的画面，和追求自由的人一起奔跑，和他们一起跑回船上。所以她在帮妇女们抱孩子，她还帮着带了两头猪，他们以邦联军官的名字给这两头猪命名，这两头猪将被送给博福特的联邦指挥官、联邦将军。她谈到有一个妇女在奔跑，
who would have been left in the slave cabins. Tubman went to the cabins to get these most vulnerable people. And she remembers this wonderful image of running with the freedom seekers, running with them back to the boats. So she's helping women carry their children. and she's helping carry these two pigs, which they named after Confederate officers and which were going to be given to the Union commanders, the Union generals back in Beaufort. And she talks about one woman who's running,
她怀里抱着孩子，裙子边挂着孩子，肩膀上还扛着一个孩子，头上顶着一个饭锅。锅还在冒烟。他们刚刚把它从火上拿下来。是的，是的。而且孩子在逃亡中还在吃东西。
she's got children in her arms and children holding on to her skirt and one child on her shoulders, and she's got a rice pot on her head. and the pot is smoking. They just pulled it off the fire. Yeah, yeah. And the child is eating in flight.
这是一个美妙的画面。塔布曼跑过稻田边缘的一些荆棘丛，把裙子撕破了。因此，她感叹自己差点把裙子撕烂，并写了一信，或者请人代笔给波士顿的妇女们，请她们寄给自己一条灯笼裤，并告诉她们自己可能在另一次远征中还需要它们。是的。是的。
It's a wonderful image. And Tubman runs through some of these like thorn bushes near the edge of the rice field and she tears her skirt. And so she laments the fact that she nearly. tour her skirt off and writes a letter or has someone write a letter for her to the women of Boston asking them to send her a pair of bloomers and telling them that she'll probably need them for another expedition. Yeah. Yeah.
这太棒了。她意识到自己只是没有穿对衣服去执行任务。没错。她要去那里营救婴儿。她需要穿裤子。她需要裤子。是的。是的。
That's amazing. She learned she just wasn't dressed for the job. Exactly. She's going in there to rescue the babies. She needs pants on. She needs pants. Yes. Yes.
种植园在燃烧。追求自由的人被用小船接走。但这毕竟是一次秘密突袭，突袭者的时间有限。在一个种植园里，奴隶主开始反击。监工设法让一些邦联士兵跟他回到种植园，他们把自己部署在追求自由的人和船之间，这阻止了许多人真正获得自由。一个被奴役的女孩逃跑了，却被冷血地枪杀。突袭者的时间用完了，当追求自由的人意识到这一点时，有些人变得绝望，试图爬上最后一批开走的小船。
Plantations are burning. Freedom seekers are being. rode to the boats. But this is, after all, a secret raid, and the raiders only have so much time. On one plantation, the slave owners started to fight back. The overseer was able to get some of the Confederate soldiers to follow him back to the plantation, and they positioned themselves between the freedom seekers and the boat, which stopped many people from actually getting to freedom. And one enslaved girl ran for it, and she was shot and killed in cold blood. The Raiders are out of time, and as freedom seekers realize this, some become desperate, trying to get on the last departing rowboats.
有描述说他们抓着小船的侧舷，试图阻止小船在没有他们的情况下离开。在某个时刻，蒙哥马利上校告诉哈莉特·塔布曼为你们的人民唱歌，唱歌来安抚他们，她照做了，他们平静下来，放开了小船的侧舷，船没有他们就开走了，所以我们只能想象那些人的遭遇，他们受到了酷刑，其中一些人可能因为试图逃跑而被杀，其中一些人可能因为试图逃跑而被卖掉。于是756人登上了船，船航行了一夜，清晨回到了博福特市中心，回到了码头。博福特，自由的绿洲，现在是10000名曾经被奴役的人过着自由生活的地方。
There were descriptions of them holding on to the sides of the rowboats and trying to stop the rowboats from leaving without them. And at one point, Colonel Montgomery tells Harriet Tubman to sing to your people, right to calm them sing to them and she does and they become calm and kind of let go of the sides of the rowboat and the boat takes off without them so we can only imagine what happened to those people that they were tortured some of them may have been killed for trying to escape some of them may have been sold for trying to escape. So 756 people get onto the boats and the boats sail all night and arrive early in the morning back in downtown Beaufort, back at the dock. Beaufort, the Oasis of Freedom, now home to 10,000 formerly enslaved people living free.
在孔巴希追求自由的人回到博福特的那个早晨。人们出来了。人们出来看望他们，排满了街道。这些人中有许多人已经自由了一年、多年，自1861年11月以来。他们有工作。他们有房子。他们有食物和衣服，他们的孩子在上学。他们把奴隶制抛在了身后。然而这里有756人，直接从稻田里走出来，正如报纸所描述的那样，他们穿着早上四点被迫劳作时穿的同样脏兮兮的灰色田野服装。报纸报道只谈到他们的身体，
And on that morning that the Cumbie Freedom Seekers arrived back. in Beaufort. People came out. People came out to see them and line the streets. And many of these people had been free, you know, for a year, years, since November, 1861. They had jobs. They had houses. They had food and clothing and their kids were in school. They had left slavery behind. And yet here were 756 people who were straight out of the rice fields, right? In the same dirty gray field clothes as the newspapers describe them that they wore to their forced labor at four o'clock in the morning. And the newspaper accounts talk about just their bodies. right skin and bones um lots of injuries people just looked sick and emaciated and broken down
骨瘦如柴，有许多伤，人们看起来生病、消瘦、精疲力竭，几乎赤身裸体，他们的身体状况糟糕透顶，但报道也谈到当他们在博福特主街游行时，他们脸上洋溢着自豪，他们洋溢着自豪，因为他们终于自由了，他们终于能够让家人团聚。迈纳斯·汉密尔顿在那里，和他的泼辣妻子海格一起走在主街上。他们的成年女儿比娜·马克也是。她也上了船，还有她的丈夫哈里和他们的小女儿（也叫海格）。
and nearly naked right they're in horrible shape physical shape but it also talks about how they're beaming with pride as they parade down the main street in Beaufort, they are beaming with pride because they are finally free, and they are finally able to reunite their families. Minas Hamilton is there, walking down the main street with his feisty wife, Hagar. So is their grown-up daughter, Bina Mack. She made it onto the boat, too, along with her husband Harry and their little daughter, also named Hagar.
泰拉·布朗、波莱特和菲比·弗雷泽在追求自由的人中找到了彼此。这些朋友曾被分开，卖到了孔巴希沿岸不同的种植园，但两人那天都上了船。有一对老夫妇叫诺瓦姆和萨拉·斯莫尔·奥斯本，是青梅竹马，最终一起获得了自由。有一个七岁的小女孩叫玛莎·辛格尔顿，还有安德鲁和黛安娜·哈里斯，他们仍在为死在种植园里的四个年幼的孩子悲伤。但他们那天带着唯一幸存的孩子来到了博福特，
Tyra Brown, Polite, and Phoebe Frazier found one another among the freedom seekers. The friends had been separated, sold two different plantations along the Combe, but both made it onto the boat that day. There's an elderly couple named November and Sarah Small Osborne, childhood sweethearts, who finally made it to freedom together. There's a seven-year-old girl named Martha Singleton, and Andrew and Diana Harris still grieving for their four small children who died back on the plantation. But they made it to Beaufort that day with their only surviving child,
一个叫塞缪尔的小男孩。我的意思是，当你想到那个场景时，你有什么感觉？这让我热泪盈眶。我也是。真的会的。真的，真的会的。想想孔巴希追求自由的人在这些水稻种植园可怕的死亡营、劳改兼死亡营里的生活是什么样子的。当他们在博福特游行时，他们终于成功了。
a little boy named Samuel. I mean, how do you feel when you think about that scene? It brings tears to my eyes. It does me too. It really does. It really, really does. Think about what the come-be freedom seekers' lives were like in these ghastly death camps, labor-slash-death camps, of these rice plantations. by the time they're parading down Beaufort, they finally made it.
他们终于自由了。那天，每个人都聚集在博福特市中心的一座教堂里，包括突袭的领导者詹姆斯·蒙哥马利上校和哈莉特·塔布曼。詹姆斯·蒙哥马利上校向追求自由的人发表了演讲，哈莉特·塔布曼紧随其后。我们不知道她说了什么。没有文字记录。而且它也不在YouTube上。噢，要是有的化。
They're finally free. That day, everyone gathers at a church in downtown Beaufort, including the leaders of the raid, Colonel James Montgomery and Harriet Tubman. Colonel James Montgomery gives a speech to the freedom seekers, and Harriet Tubman follows him. And we don't know what she said. There's no transcript. And it's not on YouTube. Oh, if only.
你的生活会容易得多。容易得多。我简直无法想象。但是，你知道，是在她的演讲之后，150名14岁到70岁的男子。有一位70岁的老人在他们获得解放的第二天早上参军，他们加入了第二南卡罗来纳志愿军。这是一件非常即时的事情：他们来解放了我们。我们要去解放其他人。这就把我们带回了我们开始这个故事的抚恤金档案。
Your life would be so much easier. So much easier. I can't even imagine. But, you know, it's after her speech that 150 men aged 14 to 70. There was one 70-year-old man who enlisted the morning after they're liberated, they enlist in the second South Carolina volunteer. It was a very immediate kind of thing that they came and liberated us. We are going to liberate others. And that brings us back to the pension files where we began this story.
我们的物品在许多方面承载了这次突袭的故事。大约有20万名黑人在内战期间服役。战争结束后，这些退伍军人、他们的遗孀、受抚养的子女有权获得军人抚恤金，就像今天的退伍军人一样。申请过程漫长而艰辛，需要大量的文书工作。无论你是黑人士兵还是白人士兵，这都不重要。你必须提供证据证明你就是你所说的那个人，并且你曾服役过。
Our object that in many ways holds the stories of this raid. About 200,000 black men served during the Civil War. And after the war is over, those men, their widows, their dependent children, were entitled to military pensions, just like veterans today. And that application process was long and laborious, and it required a lot of paperwork. It didn't matter if you were a black soldier or a white soldier. You had to provide proof that you were who you said you were and that you had served.
但不同之处在于，黑人老兵和遗孀是作为奴隶出生。所以他们没有任何文件，对吧？他们没有出生证明、结婚证明、死亡证明。老兵们拥有的是人，他们一起长大的人，他们一起参军的男人，他们娶的女人。没错。这些人出来为彼此作证。正是通过他们的证词，他们验证了彼此的身份、婚姻的神圣性、孩子的合法性、谁在何处奴役了他们，以及他们是如何被买卖、抵押、赠送，
But the difference is that the black veterans and the widows were born enslaved. So they didn't have any paperwork, right? They didn't have birth certificates, marriage certificates, death certificates. What the veterans had is they had people, people they grew up with, and the men they joined the military with and the women they married. Right. And these people came out and testified for each other. And it's through their testimony that they verify each other's identity, the sanctity of their marriages, the legitimacy of their child. children, who held them in bondage and where, and how they were bought, mortgaged, given away,
并世代传给家族内的人。然后他们谈论他们一起恋爱的生活。他们讲述了退伍军人和遗孀的整个恋爱史。因为他们必须证明他们确实与这个人合法结婚，对吧？他们没有和那些人结婚。你以一种我们从未见过的方式看到了奴隶社区中人们的整个人生，因为现在他们在讲述自己的故事。一旦你知道这些档案的存在，看到了它们以及它们产生的所有口述历史，当涉及到这次突袭时，你意识到你可以用这些档案做什么？我意识到我可以把孔巴希被奴役的社区重新拼凑起来。
and passed down to within families. And then they talk about their lives together courting. They go through the veterans and the widows' entire dating history. Because they have to show that they're actually legally married to this person, right? And they're not married to those people. You see the whole life of people in the enslaved community in ways that we've never seen them before because now they're telling their story. Once you know that these files exist and you see them and all the all the oral history that they create, what do you realize you can do with these files when it comes to the raid? I realize that I can put the, the come be enslaved community back together.
并在家族中代代相传。然后他们会谈论他们公同生活、爱悅的经历。他们会核实老兵和生存者遗姕的整个约会历史。因为他们必须证明他们确实与这个人合法结婚了，对吗？而他们并没有与那些人结婚。你会看到被奴役社区中人们的整个人生，这是以往从未见过的方式展现的，因为现在他们在讲述自己的故事。一旦你知道这些档案存在并且看到了它们以及它们所创造的所有口述历史，你会意识到对于这场袭击而言，你可以用这些档案做什么？我意识到我可以把被奴役的社区重新聚合在一起。
I realize that I can identify the people who were liberated in the raid. Those people who testified about the raid become the main characters of the story. The pension files also helped Edda rebuild her own family tree because Edda's family hails from a county not far from Beaufort. But she didn't have much to go on, just a little research her cousin had done. When I started looking for the Fields family, I went back to the notes my cousin gave me. And I saw that he had searched through the census and identified our earliest known ancestor in the 1870 census as Hector Field. But then he was stuck.
我意识到我可以辨认出在这次突袭中获得自由的人们。那些作证讲述突袭事件的人成了故事的主角。抚恤金档案也帮助埃达重建了她自己的家族树，因为埃达的家族来自离博福特不远的一个县。但她当时没有太多线索，只有她表弟做的一点点研究。当我开始寻找菲尔兹家族时，我回看了表弟给我的笔记。我发现他在人口普查中进行了搜索，并在1870年的人口普查中找到了我们所知的最早祖先赫克托·菲尔德。但随后他就卡住了。
Yeah. That's as far back as he could go. So the census said that Edda had a great, great, great, great grandmas. father named Hector. But that was kind of it. It's a dead end that people frequently hit when looking for ancestors who were enslaved. The 1870 census was the first government document that listed formerly enslaved people by first and last name, which makes it really hard to trace anyone further back than that. In fact, people call it the 1870 brick wall, a brick wall that Edda herself was facing. So how do you find Hector Fields? I was working with the
是的。那是他能追溯到的最远记录。因此人口普查显示埃达有一位曾曾曾曾祖父名叫赫克托。但基本也就这样了。这是人们在寻找被奴役的祖先时经常遇到的死胡同。1870年的人口普查是第一份按名和姓列出以前被奴役人员的政府文件，这使得要将任何人追溯到更早的时期变得非常困难。事实上，人们称之为1870年的砖墙，这是一堵埃达自己也在面对的砖墙。那么你如何找到赫克托·菲尔兹呢？我当时在与
International African American Museum Center for Family History, they identified Hector Fields as a veteran in Beaufort. So I took these little lists and I went down to the National Archives and I pulled these pension files. And Hector's file was a bust. There was no family information. It was like 30 pages long. I put it on the shelf. You know, and I looked at the other pension files. The beauty came when we discovered the pension file of Hector's brother, Jonas Fields.
国际非裔美国人博物馆家庭历史中心合作，他们将赫克托·菲尔兹认定为博福特的一名退伍军人。所以我拿着这些小名单去了国家档案馆，调阅了这些抚恤金档案。而赫克托的档案却毫无收获。里面没有任何家庭信息。它有大约30页长。我把它放在了书架上。你知道的，然后我看了看其他的抚恤金档案。美妙之处在于我们发现了赫克托的兄弟乔纳斯·菲尔兹的抚恤金档案。
This pension file, the file from Hector's brother, was more than 250 pages long, and it contained precious details about the Fields family, details that Eda never would have learned otherwise. The name of his siblings, the names of their parents, how they got separated during the war, my aunt was given away as a wedding gift, The slaveholder gave her to his daughter when she got married. So the whole, it just opened up so many doors for our family history.
这份抚恤金档案，即赫克托兄弟的档案，长达250多页，其中包含了关于菲尔兹家族的宝贵细节，这些细节是埃达原本绝无可能了解到的。他兄弟姐妹的名字，他们父母的名字，他们在战时是如何失散的，“我姑姑作为结婚礼物被送人了，奴隶主在她结婚时把她送给了他的女儿”。所以这一切，为我们的家族历史打开了太多的门。
Edda followed one document to another, one pension file to the next, until she learned something that no one in her family had known before. That Hector Fields, her great, great, great grandfather, was one of the soldiers on the Colby raid, that he took part in freeing 756 people from bondage. Her own ancestor was among those presumptuous black soldiers who set the world on fire. Of all the remarkable things that Edda was able to do with these pension files, there's one that stands apart.
埃达顺着一份文件找到另一份，从一份抚恤金档案到下一份，直到她了解到连她家里以前任何人都不知道的事情。那就是赫克托·菲尔兹，她的曾曾曾祖父，是科尔比突袭行动中的士兵之一，他参与了解放756名被奴役之人的行动。她自己的祖先就在那些敢于叫板世界、点燃世界的狂妄黑人士兵之中。在埃达利用这些抚恤金档案所做的一切了不起的事情中，有一件格外引人注目。
Not because it's the most complex, but because it may be the most basic. She was able to restore people's real names, the names of the soldiers and the freedom seekers who took part in the raid, not the names of their slaveholders, but the names they gave themselves. Jack Aiken, Sunday Briscoe, Robert and Phoebe Frasier, Captain Brown, Edward and Peggy Brown. My goal was to tell the story of the notable and the nameless, right?
不是因为它最复杂，而是因为它可能是最基础的。她能够恢复人们的真实姓名，即参与突袭的士兵和寻求自由者的名字，不是他们奴隶主的姓名，而是他们自己赋予的名字。杰克·艾肯、桑迪·布里斯科、罗伯特和菲比·弗雷泽、布朗船长、爱德华和佩吉·布朗。我的目标是讲述名人和无名之辈的故事，对吧？
The people we know and the people we don't know, the people whose names we know and the people whose names we've never heard before and their names have never been recorded before. Cuffy and Sophia Bowles, Samson Drayton, Thomas and Bella Drayton. And so how do we identify their names and tell their stories and then write their names in the annals of history? That's what I wanted to do. Carolina, Flora, and Stephanie Grant, Jackson and Jane Grant,
我们认识的人和我们不认识的人，我们知道名字的人以及我们从未听过其名字、以前从未被记录过名字的人。卡菲和索菲亚·鲍尔斯、萨姆森·德雷顿、托马斯和贝拉·德雷顿。那么我们如何确定他们的名字并讲述他们的故事，然后将他们的名字写进历史的编年史中呢？这就是我想做的。卡罗琳娜、弗洛拉和斯蒂芬妮·格兰特、杰克逊和简·格兰特、
Jeffrey and Phoebe Gray. Dr. Edda Field's Black, thank you so much for talking with me. I really enjoyed it. Thank you. Thank you for inviting me. A history of the United States and 100 Objects is a production of 99% Invisible and BBC Studios. It's hosted and curated by me, Roman Mars.
杰弗里和菲比·格雷。埃达·菲尔兹·布莱克博士，非常感谢您与我交谈。我真的很喜欢。谢谢。谢谢您邀请我。一门美国历史与100件物品是由99%无形事物与BBC工作室联合制作的节目。由我罗曼·马尔斯主持和策划。
This episode was produced by Brenna Daldorf. Our other producers are Priscilla Alabi and Ellie Lightfoot. Our associate producer is Isaac Fisher. This series was edited by Annie Brown and Courtney Harrell, mixing by Charlie Brandon King. Fact-checking by Amy Bracken. Our theme song is by Swan Real. From 99% Invisible, our executive producer is Kathy 2.
本集由布雷娜·达尔多夫制作。我们的其他制作人是普里西拉·阿拉比和埃利·莱特富特。我们的副制作人是艾萨克·费舍尔。本系列由安妮·布朗和考特尼·哈雷尔剪辑，混音由查理·布兰登·金完成。事实核查由埃米·布拉肯完成。我们的主题曲由斯旺·里尔创作。来自99%无形事物，我们的执行制作人是凯茜2。
From BBC studios, our executive producers are Annie Brown and Courtney Harrell. Our production coordinator is Shan Palais, and the production manager is Mabel Finnegan Wright, artwork by Stefan Lawrence. 99% Invisible is part of the Serious XM podcast family, headquartered in Beautiful, Uptown, Oakland, California. And BBC Studios is headquartered in beautiful,
来自BBC工作室，我们的执行制作人是安妮·布朗和考特尼·哈雷尔。我们的制作协调员是珊·帕莱，制作经理是梅贝尔·芬尼根·赖特，插图由斯特凡·劳伦斯绘制。99%无形事物是严肃XM播客家族的一部分，总部位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰美丽的上城。BBC工作室总部位于美丽且
White City, West London. If you want to get in touch or have an object for us to consider, email us at 100 Objects at 99PI, org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
西伦敦的白城。如果您想与我们联系或有物品希望我们考虑，请发电子邮件至100 Objects at 99PI, org。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。